okay today I'm going to talk to you
about preparing insoluble salts so this
is how to make an insoluble salt so
first of all insoluble means something
which doesn't dissolve so I need to make
a particular salt now let's say I was
trying to make barium sulfate so I
trying to make this substance called
barium sulfate how would I go about
doing this experimentally so variants of
8 is an insoluble salt but in order to
make it I need to soluble salts or two
things that will dissolve in water in
order to make this so one of them must
contain barium otherwise I wouldn't be
able to get barium sulfate an example of
one of these could be for example barium
nitrate now I need to react this with
something which is soluble and contains
a sulfate such as potassium sulfate so
this is the chemical reaction that I'm
going to do I'm going to mix together my
barium sulfate very nitrate sorry with
my potassium sulfate now the reason why
this gives barium sulfate is because
it's essentially a displacement reaction
potassium is more reactive than barium
so it replaces it making potassium
nitrate and the barium replaces the
potassium to make barium sulfate so
barium sulfate is one of the products
the other product is going to be
potassium nitrate okay so I'm not
actually interested in potassium nitrate
here I'm only interested in making this
stuff here varium sulfate so let's see
how I go about doing this so these are
two soluble salts that I start off with
now I'm wanting them to react together
but to begin with they are solid so I
can't just mix them together these two
salts I can't mix them together and they
react as they are what I need to do is I
need to
dissolve them in water so I add both of
these to a test tube and I also add
distilled water so distilled water is
just really really pure water that's
been purified through the distillation
process so I've added distilled water to
both of those so now I've dissolved both
of these salts in water so barium
nitrate has gone in there and potassium
sulfate spawn a net now they're
dissolved in solution I can now react
them together so what I do next is I'm
going to add them I had both of these
test tubes of pour them into this beaker
here again I'm mixing them together so
that will those in there and that one
goes in there so I can now have this
chemical reaction going on to make
barium sulfate now variance of a barium
sulfate remember is insoluble in solid
which means it doesn't dissolve in water
so as we mix these two liquids together
we get something forming called
a precipitate and what a precipitate is
is when we mix two liquids together and
a solid is formed because it's insoluble
so we've done what we wanted to do we've
made our barium sulfate but the
unfortunate thing is we've still got a
lot of potassium nitrate all around it
and we still have all of this liquid to
get rid of so our next step is filtering
it so we get a bit of filter paper and a
funnel and what we do is we get this
beaker sorry we get this beaker and we
tip the contents into our filter paper
so here we have a conical flask as well
so what happens is this insoluble barium
sulfate now it's a solid that gets stuck
in the filter paper like this whereas
all of the rest of the solution of
potassium nitrate goes through here and
into the conical flask so we've managed
to cook 30 we've managed to separate our
barium sulfate so now it's all in the
filter paper what we do next is we
actually just get some distilled water
in one of those squeezy bottles and we
just squirt some of the still water to
wash all of the potassium nitrate off
our barium sulfate so we're just left
with barium sulfate remember that's what
we're interested in so the final thing
that we need to do is we take out our
filter paper and we open it up so here's
our filter paper and on it is our barium
sulfate so here is our insoluble salt
that we were trying to make barium
sulfate and all that we do is leave it
on this unfolded filter paper for it to
dry and then we prepared our insoluble
salt so to quickly recap to make an
insoluble salt we have to react together
to soluble salts one containing the
metal part that we're interested in and
one containing the the other part we're
interested in what we've then need to do
is because we start off with the big and
the solid are being solid they don't
react together when they're solid so we
need to dissolve them in distilled water
in test tubes then we mix them together
in a beaker because our insoluble salt
doesn't dissolve in water we form a
precipitate so this is what we're trying
to make however we need to get this out
of solution so what we do is we filter
it
using filter paper a funnel and a
conical flask we wash it through with
distilled water and then finally we
unfold the filter paper and leave it to
dry thank you